hello and and welcome to the Center for
teaching and learning for today's
closing presentations in a sense of the
2017-2018 round of the Rosencrantz
grants for pedagogical advancements I'm
Tripp Patrick I'm associate director for
educational technology here and I'll
start by thanking Robert Rosencrantz our
funder without which whom none of this
would be possible but also in all
seriousness for his interest in funding
the exploration of digital technology's
possibilities for positive and
thoughtful most importantly thoughtful
contributions to teaching and learning
in our annual call for proposals in
selection process and I'll say something
about the grants in just a second we we
try to look for projects that put
digital technologies at the service of
working out meaningful changes in
teaching and learning the Rosencrantz
grants are up to $10,000 we offer them
we've this will be the third cohort that
you'll see today and the call will open
up again in November and we look for
things that are making an intervention
with digital technology in the service
of teaching and learning I'm really
looking forward to the proposals today
and you didn't come here to listen to me
so that'll be basically that except for
two logistical points one is that we're
gonna have each presentation and then
some Q&A after it and then if and as we
have time and interest at the end we'll
have some more open discussion some of
our presenters unfortunately are gonna
have to leave before that point but
since part of what we want to do with
this is to share the work that's getting
done and to see how other people might
think of these if you have a question
that can't get answered for one reason
or another contact me I'll get you in
contact with the project people and we
can get it happen the others that we're
gonna have a short break in the middle
we're gonna have three presentations and
then a break and then another three so
if you can save whatever reason you
would otherwise have to leave until the
break which should be at about one
o'clock then that would be great so so
in our first cluster and I'll just do it
all now so we can let them go we're
going to hear from in order Steve
Stearns and Madeline case right okay
from ecology and evolutionary biology on
their team's project training 21st
century educators to
plain science to the world le and then
the next group at least Wang Christopher
tore me and Alexis Sidon from the School
of Medicine departments of internal
medicine laboratory medicine and
pathology with their project on a
multidisciplinary interactive digital
peripheral smear course for medical
students and Beyond and then for the end
of the first cluster Cerritos Waris and
Brian Brown from the School of
Medicine's internal medicine primary
care residency program talking about
sugar-coated science animating and
anthropomorphizing drugs molecules and
cells to enhance medical training
diabetes education Thanks then we'll get
going hi everybody so I would like to
report on a project that was designed to
teach graduate students and postdocs how
to give short online lectures that would
be effective when presented on the world
wide web and we had nine people that
decided to take part the idea basically
was to Train PhD students and postdocs
and how to give a clear compelling
concise online lecture we also want to
showcase the diversity of competent
young scientists and thereby provide
images of role models for the world we
wanted to provide content that was
helpful inappropriate for ap biology
courses and for introductory
college-level biology courses that could
be used as resources for teachers we
also wanted our job candidates to be
able to put a URL on their CV and say
click here if you want to see me teach
and in addition to that we wanted to
provide a method for our faculty to say
we have satisfied the nih and NSF
outreach requirements because our
students are going out and they are not
only doing this on the web they're
practicing their talks at high schools
so we got going
this year and we had a few setbacks
basically what we discovered is that our
PhD students and postdocs are very busy
which will not surprise you as a result
we have one person Maddy who has
completed the process with the exception
that we have not yet recorded so
basically the money that we got from
Rosencrantz is for the professional
recording and editing so that when we
present ourselves to the world it looks
professional we don't need that if we
want to walk into that room over there
and practice that's free okay so we're
gonna do that before we go down to
College Street and get into the studio
and these guys will do the usual job
that they do on people like me okay so
the reason that I had this idea is
basically that I have recorded two full
courses a total of nearly 90 lectures
that are up on the web and I've been
impressed by the impact they've had
worldwide I've been getting emails now
for about nine years on those and I
thought that this would be a good way to
help our grad students and postdocs get
the kind of teaching experience that
might be relevant for them 10 20 years
down the road in fact is probably
relevant tomorrow so I'll turn it over
to Maddie and Maddie can tell you how
the process worked
hi I'm Madi case I'm a fourth-year PhD
student in the ebee department and one
of the participants in this program this
year and the process that we developed
was designed to give us lots of
opportunity for feedback and also for
giving other people a chance to learn
from what we were doing so each one of
us participating in this has developed
two paired 15-minute lectures the first
on a general topic in ecology or
evolutionary biology and the second on
our own research as an example of how
actual scientists do that that kind of
work so most of us started from the
point of that second lecture thinking
about what is something that I've done
that would be exciting that I'd like to
share and then zooming out and seeing
what is the larger topic that that fits
and that that fits into so for myself I
work on plant ecology in African
savannas and I designed my second
lecture to talk about work that I had
done looking at vegetation change in an
African savanna and my first lecture to
put that in context I talked about what
determines vegetation around the world
and what determines vegetation change
and what all of us have have done with
these lectures is first practice them in
front of an audience of our peers which
is that in the Evy Department every
Friday afternoon we have an informal
seminar series that we call the
speakeasy where it's usually grad
students or postdocs giving talks and so
we use that as a forum to give practice
talks and to get feedback from a bunch
of other grad students and postdocs who
all have some teaching experience and we
could talk to each other about what was
working what wasn't thinking a lot about
how to tailor our talks when most of us
are used to mostly talking to scientific
audiences how do we pitch these to AP
biology or early college students so
that was the first round of feedback and
then after doing that we edit the talk
some more and then take the
to an audience closer to the target
audience which is an AP biology class at
a nearby high school which it's also in
its own right a form of outreach
reaching local high school students
showing them what Yale students are
doing and how exciting science can be
and it was an incredible way to get
feedback so I did this recently visiting
co-op high school here downtown and got
a lot of feedback from them about what
was the most exciting in my presentation
which will help in doing a final round
of edits on these lectures before
creating some polished filmed lectures
to put it online at every stage I've
been learning about how to make a good
lecture and we've also been doing things
that the people watching us can learn
from ultimately the final product of
this is also going to be something that
benefits me as someone who is going to
be applying for jobs we're having some
evidence of my teaching abilities as
useful but will also benefit anyone who
can access these lectures online and
learn something about biology thank you
so we'll both be up here if you have
questions but I'd like to add a couple
of things one is that if this works we'd
like this to be possible for every PhD
student and postdoc at Yale University
online we want to get feedback and so
forth but I think it's the kind of thing
that represents a really sensible
investment in the training of our
graduate students and postdocs to be
teachers um the other thing I want to
mention is that when we went down to the
magnet school and walked into that room
there was one white guy in the audience
three Hispanic males and about 25
african-american females that was the
target audience Maddy is a woman but
she's not a black woman and I was really
feeling at that point that I would like
to have or
model that would stand up that actually
looked like the audience I must say that
the audience didn't seem to be fazed at
all and they gave you lots of yeah they
were great they have Madi handed out
questionnaires and they sold out all
kinds of things and they actually had
quite a bit of given tape with her when
we finishes the next person who's
presenting decided that it would be nice
to invite the students to Yale rather
than going down to the magnet school so
she's doing it at 17 Hill House in the
teaching room at 17 Hill House and the
students are coming to Yale which i
think is great because it helps them to
realize that oh maybe I could do this so
I think that's good for high school
students and with that we have a few
minutes for questions I'm going to have
to run because I have to catch a train
to New York you know sorry
what does the assessment look like this
person mentions feedback questionnaires
with students that you visited and the
informal feedback from your peers is
there more extensive assessment before
you rolled this out to all that's all
PhD students um yes we're planning on
first getting assessment from the people
who have done it after they've done it
so we're gonna get we're going to write
a report on that we have not yet worked
out exactly how we're going to get
feedback from the web okay and so that's
in development but that would be a very
sensible thing to do we can certainly do
things like monitor numbers of hits and
gathers standard web-based statistics on
it it would be more meaningful to find
out whether or not it actually did its
job in the substantive sense that we
haven't figured out
David trying to reach yeah I think
that's something that I've developed
through this process certainly the first
time when I gave this talk at the
speakeasy to my peers the second talk
was very similar to talks that I had
given at conferences and but everyone
listening in the audience was helping me
by putting them into the mindset of
someone who hadn't seen this before and
saying like that figure is way too
complicated what is the actual message
here and so that's something I worked a
lot on before bringing these talks to
high school students thinking about what
is the real story that I need to get
across without I don't have to talk
about all the statistics I need to focus
on what did we learn from this and
another thing that I focused a lot on
that all of us in the program have been
trying to do is to put more of ourselves
into these presentations to not have
them just be dry you know here's what I
can tell you about global vegetation in
both of them the first presentation I
open with talking about how I come from
Oregon and talking about the contrast
between eastern and western Oregon in
terms of what the vegetation looks like
on either side of the mountains and
using that to set up this whole topic of
you know why is one place a desert in
one place of forest and similarly in the
the second talk I tried to put some of
myself into it pictures of myself in the
field doing the research talking about
how what did this mean to me and that
was something that I got a lot of
positive feedback on from the students
that we spoke to that they thought it
was really cool that I had actually done
this work myself and that was something
that made it exciting to them we shared
that kind of experience among all of
them and we're trying to make sure that
everybody tries to build something like
that into the talks
but I think as you've seen one of the
great things about the project is that I
tried to give people agency as they went
through Madi and an event actually wrote
the Rosencrantz proposal and as you can
see she's very charming she's very
comfortable in her own skin she's a
really good ambassador for this kind of
stuff and in a sense I'm totally
irrelevant I'm a cheerleader pull out
even yet farther is this an advantage
for the students or is this bringing you
up to par no ever since is this becoming
just a thing that everybody who's hiring
somebody wants to see no or is this you
what's what's the career and job context
for these things that in my experience
well Maddie hasn't been on the market
yet but I've been looking at candidates
and I can tell you I've never seen a
candidate that brought anything like
this to the table and I think it's going
to give in the early years it'll give
our students an edge but I suspect that
if it proves to be effective it will
very rapidly spread and then everybody
will do it and then it'll just be
standard that would be great that might
be ten years down the road but at the
moment I think that it will definitely
be helpful and it will depend on the
kind of job that people are applying for
it will be more important if you're
trying to get a teaching position at a
liberal arts college than if you're
trying to become a professor at
Rockefeller University which is only
grad student research but I would think
that for many of our students it should
be quite helpful
[Applause]
well good afternoon and thank you for
having us at talk a little bit about our
project today on behalf of my
collaborators dr. Alexis iddin and dr.
Chris Burt or me I'd like to present
some highlights from our project that
was funded by last year's rosencrantz
grant entitled a multidisciplinary
interactive jitter peripheral smear
course for medical students and beyond
so it was a pretty wordy title but I
think this slide will kind of give us a
little bit of background in terms of
what we are presenting today
so to begin I'd like to bring your
attention to the importance of
peripheral blood smear analysis which is
a very useful and cost effective tool
for patient care and not only aids in
the diagnosis of various blood disorders
but also in a variety of illnesses that
present would blood cell abnormalities
and in the schematic below we present to
you sort of the gist of this here we
have a patient's drop of blood which is
placed on one end of a glass slide and
then we have in the center here we have
a second slide which is the spreader
slide which is then used to smear that
drop a blood to make a more uniform
layer so that we won't have very many
overlapping cells the slide is then
stained and then it is ready to be
viewed under the microscope and so for
this last portion we can then look at it
from a bird's eye view where under low
power magnification we can see the
majority of the cells as we scan through
various fields but then as we move up in
the power of magnification we can
certainly then focus in on individual
cell structures and identify things much
more readily so on this slide we bring
up some representative peripheral blood
smears and on the left hand side if you
focus on the two big cells with the
purple nuclei
one of the things we can readily tell is
as we look at the cellular structures
these slides are under high power
magnification so we can see that there
are differences between the nucleus as
well as the cytoplasm of these cells and
if you look on the right-hand side of
the big cell with the purple nucleus
you'll see that the cytoplasm is much
larger and that the cytoplasm also hugs
or skirts the other surrounding red
blood cells which is quite different
than the much more round shape of the
other white blood cell here and so
that's one of the things that when we're
looking at white blood cells which are
part of the immune system so are these
cells that are reacting to some process
so for example if a patient is coming in
with a viral syndrome are these actually
reactive types of lymphocytes one type
of white blood cell of the immune system
versus are they much more concerning in
terms of a malignant appearing white
blood cell that could be signs that the
patient is actually presenting with a
severe cancer like a leukemia moving on
to the right hand side that slide we see
a different type of white blood cell so
again looking at the purple nuclear
you'll see that there there are many
more lobes and this is a neutrophil and
this slide is actually meant to focus in
on a type of platelet related disorder
that is inherited so even though the
platelets is actually to the left here
the little fuzzy bits sort of smaller
than the majority of the cells that are
red blood cells in this particular
inherited disorder one of the things we
actually look at our white blood cells
and some of the inclusions that we may
see as well and if you look at the
bottom of that neutrophil you'll see
that maybe at the back room it might be
a little fuzzier but basically it's a
bluish gray kind of inclusion body and
that's pretty classic for this type of
platelet disorder that has a bleeding
tendency for patients for them a
headland anomaly and so the last
representative slide here is focusing on
really red blood cells so you don't see
the cells with the purple nuclei now but
you see that the shapes are different
and
so in this case we generally think of
red blood cells as biconcave when it
goes through the vessels it should be
able to deform to squeeze through the
smaller blood vessels so in general it's
by concave and we'll see central area of
clearing that looks more white and then
the surrounding red pinkish cell but
you'll see closer to the center that
there cells that are elongated so this
one is in a patient who presents with a
pain crisis so that type of cell shape
is a sickle cell shape and this patient
has an underlying disorder of sickle
cell anemia so these types of slide
reviews are so important but
unfortunately hematology courses
nationwide have increasingly
de-emphasized this type of training and
also in the practical use of microscopes
there is evidence however that there is
increasing demand for this type of
peripheral blood smear interpretation
from a clinical perspective and
certainly we know that experts that are
able to assist in an interpretation of
urgent cases unfortunately are not
available in a 20-4 setting even in the
hospital eyes case where for example in
urgent cases where timely and
appropriate identification of certain
blood cell abnormalities may change
management of patients and sometimes it
can be critical in terms of even
life-or-death situations locally at the
Yale School of Medicine peripheral blood
smear education is limited to a handful
of workshops which is superficial in
scope and so in talking to our course
director the universal feedback he has
received from first-year medical
students certainly has been more smears
the need for additional training is also
validated in my area so I'm a
hematologist oncologist and my fellows
in training certainly tell us that they
also would like much more exposure and
teaching in this aspect and one of the
things that my collaborators and I did
sort of seeing informally this request
was to see
was there really a knowledge deficit and
so in taking our first year hematology
fellows before they started our training
program we actually did a series of
smears with clinical vignettes and asked
them to take that at the beginning of
their fellowship and at the end of the
first year of training so certainly in
terms of the pre testing there was
evidence of a knowledge deficit and on
on average the score was 64% with a
range of 44 to 78% and even with one
year of of teaching and exposure to more
smears on the post testing there was
only marginal improvement and the
average score was only in the 70% range
so there's certainly still a need in
addition a recent study performed by my
colleagues at Yale's affiliated VA
showed that as you look in this pie
chart here at the blue area 58 percent
of electronic consults to the facility's
lab medicine service were in the domain
of hematology and all of the hematology
consoles were actually for assistance
with peripheral blood smear
interpretation so one of the very
gratifying things in my field is the
ability to have a built-in teamwork in
terms of multi-modality care for
patients and this has been a really nice
way to also expand this in terms of the
growing need for additional peripheral
blood smear education and access so in
addition to the knowledge I bring in
hematology and oncology my colleagues to
my right dr. Sidon and dr. Tommy from
pathology and Laboratory Medicine and
two additional collaborators that I will
talk a little bit about their work as
well in cell biology and also in another
area of internal medicine so we are very
grateful to have received funding from
the rosencrantz grant and so our target
our audience for our
project with certainly Yale medical
students primarily first-year medical
students but also a secondary audience
would also be in the post graduates
hematology oncology fellows and also
affiliated disciplines laboratory
medicine and pathology etc so our our
Ames primary certainly was to create an
online interactive educational
supplement to medical student classroom
peripheral blood smear learning and so
it our goal was accomplished with two
ways the first one really was to collect
a library of slides based on the
patients that we would see that had
slides scanning them to make them
available in digital form but also using
software by one of our collaborators to
be able to use a Google map sort of
linking system to be able to tag normal
and abnormal cells and to be able to
link them to Question and Answer with
associated clinical vignettes and then
the second portion was to also have an
animated series particularly focusing on
normal and abnormal blood seldom
development available for student review
after class secondary goal would
certainly to be to expand this online
course from the above basics to a more
advanced level for a postgraduate
education so the latter portion of our
toggle will just give you an update
about where we are and what we've done
so far so as you can tell we're trying
to be HIPAA compliant so we've kind of
glued out because these are actual cases
that we have been involved with from the
clinical setting but basically a tray of
slides with both normal blood cells but
also a number of other conditions
approximately thirty but it continues to
grow so this is not inclusive but one of
the things that is helpful in terms of
blood smear is to realize that it can be
helpful and many other conditions not
just blood related so in the top portion
various infections may present with
blood cell abnormalities and so things
endemic to this region like Babesia for
example less common malaria and other
but certainly very commonly around this
time of year still a lot of viral
infections going on the flu and things
like that and so we may see reactive
lymphocytes the cell I showed before in
the past slide etc but then also people
who are deficient in nutrients may
manifest with blood cell abnormalities
so iron deficiency b12 deficiency etc
then we have certainly benign hematology
disorders some of which are inborn so
hereditary States others of which are
acquired hemolytic anemia as we talked
briefly about sickle cell anemia etc but
certainly from the standpoint of cancer
there are also cancers that can be
readily found in the bloodstream
primarily leukemias and sometimes
lymphoma cancers of the lymph nodes can
be found circulating in the bloodstream
as well and so we do have some
representative cases of that so in terms
of our primary objective this was the
first part in terms of having a library
of slides scanning and so this is to
show sort of where we are and some of
the representative slides one
sickle-cell so here is a link that will
kind of show you so when I showed you
the three represented smears that's a
pretty artificial way in terms of
learning because unfortunately when
someone is faced with a smear that they
need to look under the microscope that's
not what you automatically see so
basically if you are under low power
magnification
and you have this slide you will kind of
see this from a birth idea just lots of
little dots that size so you want to go
higher magnification then you can start
to see so you can see for example the
red blood cells different shapes I told
you that the nucleus with purple
generally white blood cells for example
so we can also look a little bit more so
we can start to look a little too quick
at the internal structures but basically
one of the things we are able to do is
you will see under low power
magnification you have to scan in a lot
of different fields and that what you
see in one field may be quite different
so larger fields make larger cells may
clump together more in the edges of the
slides so you have to be careful where
you look if you are in an area where
there are too many overlapping cells
that may actually be artifact and not
truly what is going on with the patient
that you are trying to take care of and
certainly one thing that we know is that
we see a lot of different strange
appearing cells but if you only see one
of them in many many fields it's
unlikely to be clinically important and
again we always want to bring it back to
the patient so that's a very important
so once we get into high-power field
certainly we are much more able to
identify the nuclear structures the
cytoplasm are there granules those
little dots inside the cytoplasm of
certain inclusion bodies that they're
there etc and so the additional
component that we are able to do with
our cell biology collaborator dr. peter
Takizawa is to really based on google
maps and highlighting for example this
one would be taken from Google Maps
right highlighting different locations
and you can zoom in zoom out similarly
we're able to do that in our low power
to high power where if we want to then
link we are able to individually tag
cells and then also link it to questions
and answers and get automatic feedback
to patients and to know how to design
further so the second portion of our
project really was to do animated series
stay explain one of the things about
hematology is it's a very visual field
and one of the things is it can be hard
to kind of understand the development of
the nucleus for example and the top part
of the field is red blood cell
development from the most immature where
it's in the bone marrow to the mature
where the this part the erythrocyte is
ready to go into the circulation which
is where we typically see on our
peripheral blood smear so typically we
would not see the larger cells with the
larger nucleus we would see the mature
form so we can kind of see and then slow
it down and kind of explain each of the
differences to kind of zoom in this is
the normal red blood cell development on
the top to zoom in how about abnormal
blood cells because that's a lot of what
we see
well this again is another
representative animation and this one is
done with our internal medicine
collaborator dr. Arnold Marley err where
we asked him to show how a bite cell is
for him so this is an the sleeve where
we have a red cell with hemoglobin which
forms red blood cells but excess so
these little purple dots really are
excess it's trying to squeeze through a
slit of the basement membrane of the
endothelial cell as it's trying to
squeeze through those denatured
hemoglobin Heinz bodies sort of get left
behind pinched off and then the
remaining red blood cell membrane closes
but the shape remaining is not normal
and it's this bite deformity so in
conclusion where are we in terms of our
objectives so we have some
representative samples from both the
slide library and the Google mapping as
well as the animation but we
not completed it so we're currently in
the process of scanning the remaining
cases labeling the remaining slides
doing additional cell developmental
scenarios making the QA and evaluations
and certainly our main hope was to be
able to incorporate this into the 2019
Yale medical student curriculum and so
to upload it into the database there and
to implement it eventually to the
postgraduate level with this our hope is
also for presentation at a national
meeting with publication afterward and
with this educational tool also to be
able to provide it potentially to
students and trainees outside the Yale
medical community as well so thank you
for your time attention and if you have
any questions we'd be happy to answer
[Applause]
through the trouble of essentially
labeling a large database of these cells
whether you consider using machine
learning approaches to automate easier
said than done
one of our colleagues actually in our
Department of Laboratory Medicine is
actually working on that exact tool from
a research perspective but it's in its
infancy right now really I think we're
at the point where we help the machine
to learn how to recognize morphology we
actually considered that as part of one
of our initial as we were writing
proposals up it was just we actually
consulted with this individual it was
just too much of its infancy stage at
this point I think probably in five to
ten years it's probably gonna be
something very realistic that we may be
relying a lot more on machine learning
but just a little too not quite as fully
developed normal and abnormal as a
spectrum so it's not binary black and
white and there there are a lot of
real-world complications in terms of
slide artifact and a lot of thing
that really the machine may not
necessarily interpret correctly so
which maybe in some ways relate that
which is what is the what is it sort of
a rate of change how often is this slide
live are you going to need to be adapted
or is it reasonably fixed yeah so so
there is a reasonable number of common
diagnoses that we see that once the
library is complete it's always nice
when you get a really great example to
update it because some of these some of
these things are very rare we only see
them maybe once or twice a year and if
the slide isn't beautiful is if it's
nothing the most like most textbook
example it would be great to continue to
update it but with respect to your
question there are maybe ten diagnoses
that are life or death we need to know
about them now in the next few hours and
so those are the ones that were kind of
at the top of our list that we want to
make sure our medical students and
fellows are most comfortable with so
those are our our priorities right now
so our the trainees that I oversee in
hematology and oncology so it's a
combined service so in hematology there
are cancers of the blood but also non
cancer related diseases and so when our
fellows in training take call so
basically a patient that they may never
have seen know nothing about and they
they're the first one to respond when
they take call one of the first things
that they kind of in terms of prepping
you know the trainees we tell them that
hematology call convene one of the most
nerve-racking calls because some of the
you get called in the middle of the
night and you have to come in to see if
this person has acute leukemia for
example because there are some some that
we we need to treat that very day that
and where ours can even make a
difference or if there's destruction of
blood cells where we actually need to
call on our colleagues to actually
recirculate their blood and remove
certain things where again ours can be
essential and so where we find that lack
of this exposure and trainee really
comes to a place where it makes it to be
particularly
big challenge for all involved trip also
answer I think answer part of your
question was we're using very very
classic scenarios that really probably
if you look at a textbook from the early
1900's probably have the same
terminology so the rate of change I
think is actually quite small it's not
like we're not going to be using
guideline documents or things that
change on a frequent basis so I think
the this will be able to last in
perpetuity for quite a while as Alexa so
we could certainly add more rare
entities in but I think one of the
beauties of this is that it really
doesn't change all that much it
unlike treatment diagnosis are served
are what they are so that's actually a
nice aspect of this heavy database thank
you this is fascinating
um one question about the technology
used to create the high fidelity images
and the ability to zoom in and talking a
little bit about
eConsult and whether there's a mechanism
for the lab to be able to use that
technology so that if a fellow or a
trainee was concerned that I I think
that this is a concerning blood smear I
want to review it with a hematologist at
3 in the morning before I you know Colin
you know the whole team is that a future
direction that might be applicable and
something that might allow for like
real-time feedback of interpretations a
really good question so right now um we
do do laboratory 8 consults although Ted
look at the blood smear in the middle of
the night is not something that we can
currently do however going back to your
art AI question are the newest series of
blood analyzers they do actually make
these smears and they do take pictures
of them and they try to categorize their
selves the cells they're not nearly as
good as humans are but one of the
aspects of them that we are trying to
take advantage of and will probably
happen the next few years at least is
remote access to those things so then we
will be able to remotely look at these
these cells it's really helpful actually
for like off site small outreach clinics
where there's maybe an urgent clinical
question or there's like a an
intracellular parasite it it
it would be a really useful technology
and it's coming it's not quite primetime
yet a lower tech way is you can actually
take it with a smartphone and so it the
quality is not going to be as good but
you can still get a lot of useful
information and you take a picture from
the microscope using the smartphone and
then text it to the expert thank you for
this opportunity to speak to you
and my name is Sarita source of one of
the faculty members in the primary care
internal medicine department and I'll be
presenting with my resident colleague
dr. Brian Brown about our project
sugar-coated science in search of the
medical education media best practices
so a little bit of background in our
primary care program we've been trying
to utilize more utilize more flipped
classroom technology to really uh
optimize the time that we have with our
learners both our residents and our
medical students as medicine
proliferates there's more and more
content that needs to be covered and
using adult learning theory modalities
we recognize that we have a digital
native group of learners and rather than
spend time in the class going over
background knowledge and just in a pure
knowledge transfer we can actually use
her in classroom time to apply back that
knowledge to real patients and practice
clinical reasoning techniques we also
want to make the the resources that we
use for kind of pre work s fun and
engaging as possible because we
recognize that our residents and our
medical students are quite busy we want
them to really want to engage in the
material and our kind of educational
theory here was that if we use advanced
organizers which are kind of scaffold or
things like analogies or acronym
that help learners translate complex
material into something which is a
little bit easier to retain that we
could actually help to make those
flipped classrooms a little bit more fun
rather than using things like a mnemonic
we wanted to explore the use of
animation and medical education as an
opportunity to work as an advanced
organizer so for a little bit of a
little bit more background a couple of
the educational theories that we wanted
to take into account what's balancing
the cognitive load theory so what you're
gonna have our learners have some
sensory information that's gonna be in
their working memory and what we want to
see is how are we gonna be able to
translate that into long-term memory but
we want to do that in a way that's not
going to put too much germane load so if
we're gonna use videos we want those
videos to be engaging but not so
engaging that it distracts learners from
the content that we want them to acquire
and so that that's something that's been
published about using videos and using
animation and videos and so we wanted to
study that as we look at our advanced
organizers the other thing is we wanted
to evaluate multimedia learning theory
RTL coding theory and looking at the
synergy between sound and visual aspects
and how they kind of activate our
sensory parts of our brain which can
really enhance that long term
acquisition of knowledge and forming
like durable memories so the objectives
of our project were to assess the
feasibility of developing this digital
animation skill set especially as a
clinician educator so Brian and I are
both trained as physicians but we've
been getting more educational skill sets
as we go neither of us have been trained
in animation but is this something that
is feasible for a clinician to learn so
that they can apply this as an
educational tool like lace you want to
study a series of best practices to
again optimize that that balance between
cognitive load while we're using these
animations as an advanced organizer and
then lastly we wanted to evaluate our
learners to see how they want you know
videos or flipped classrooms
that use animation to be developed so
that we can take this one project and
hopefully scale it up in other areas for
educational curriculum one pass this
over to Mike
so thanks Rita so uh you know to take
all this jargon and kind of give you an
example of what these advanced
organizers might look like I figure
rather than us telling you we'd have the
characters themselves
well yeah but you ended up liking it
yeah we getting some awesome footage it
was totally
from the okay
just yeah need to make sure you get so
that so yeah so we wanted to find the
intersection between all this sort of
adult learning theory of multimedia
learning theory and then take some of
the skill sets of people actually in the
trade that we were learning as novices
and find the intersection of those two
and so to approach this unique topic we
had to use a mixed methods to develop
our lessons so first of all we did you
that literature review around some of
that learning here you just heard about
and then it was some just kind of late
for internet searches about you know
have you learned how to animate what are
the online resources to do that what are
the tutorials sort of the skills there's
a lot of fun with that and some of the
logos I throw up here are some of those
free programs that people want know
later I can go I can tell you more about
those and then we just kind of journaled
along the way all of our lessons learned
about what is useful use of our time
what is not worth learning like CGI and
then we did do a pretest for our
learners so we were teaching
specifically about diabetes and the
drugs used for them and so we we did a
pretest about that and I'll talk about
that briefly later and then our main
thing was that as we created these video
products we then did a focus group as a
way of qualitatively assessing they'll
learn a response so this is a graphic of
a wheel that's almost like a variant on
the PDSA cycle from the quality
improvement world that we developed kind
of in our process as a what we think is
a good step-by-step guide to creating a
educational piece of multimedia and I'll
mention in the research piece so briefly
discussing key stakeholders for us that
was
to the person who's in charge of our
diabetes curriculum and saying can we do
this learner survey needs assessment
I'll mention and then content research
was just making sure we knew about the
information before we try to teach it
and and then there was other specific
ones as far as actually creating the
video from there I'll I'll go into
another slides so as far as character
design that's one piece I want to
highlight of something I learned from
the animation tutorial world but I think
it's kind of cool from an educational
standpoint there's this idea and
developed in um in the world of design
the four DS of development and so the
first D for our Segal character for
example we had to discover or research
references so pictures of real seagulls
as well as other people have made
cartoon seagulls what did they emphasize
and D emphasized then the design stage
is your trial and error where you're
gonna just make lots of sketches of what
your character might look like taking
the features that you liked or didn't
like from previous examples and then
develop is where you refine your design
and design you know decide what
accessories is gonna have in this case
it's part of what makes it educational
and finally deliver which refers to the
finished product which in our case was
just going ahead and making the videos
for another animator it might be
pitching it to the client or something
like that another key piece I wanted to
talk about as far as the actual
development process is storyboarding and
I want you to get a sense that one of
the overarching themes here is all the
steps of planning that you do to develop
a piece of multimedia before you
actually make it can really pay off
because you can collaborate with your
team members even if they're non you
know members of the team that are not
specifically involved in making the
actual video they can provide their
feedback and input and be included each
of these steps and it helps you not have
to backpedal later because as you'll see
the actual animation step is pretty time
consuming so storyboarding is kind of
self-explanatory but basically you want
to plan out what each shot is gonna show
just like in any movie or show in this
case it's because you want to have you
know those images they're gonna maximize
your intrinsic load and keep the
distracting stuff um on the periphery as
much as possible so here's an example of
a storyboard for our upcoming episode
three actually but you can see it's very
quick kind of sketches and then some
animation
we started making with little notes and
arrows it could be very sloppy but it's
very useful as a communication tool okay
so as far as the learner needs
assessment I didn't show all the data
here but very briefly basically folks
were really excited about the idea of
watching a video to learn more about the
topic these are the two drug classes we
did our first episodes on metformin is
the most commonly used drug so you can
see that by the end of intern year
our folks are pretty comfortable but for
one of the new more very highly
effective but one of the kind of highly
effective newer drug classes the sglt2
inhibitors which the Siegel actually was
even by the end of engineer and our
prior curriculum people were so very
uncomfortable and were under utilizing
these drugs and helping her patients so
briefly on the actual animating part and
again this is stuff I could talk about
all day but you know I can take
questions afterwards so I put up just a
few examples of some of the types of
workflows we came to ended up doing with
the software we ended up getting used to
and everything and so in this one we're
using type of animation called vector
animation which okay so vector animation
which is where you have a kind of it's a
2d image and you create these digital
shapes that are very easy to manipulate
over a timeline so once you make them
it's very easy to animate so we start
with a pencil sketch you take a phone
picture of it so that's the only step
that really cause any artistic ability
and then from there you upload it into
free software and you can vectorize it
that you can animate it in another
program and then use something like
iMovie to kind of put the final touches
another example I won't belabor this for
the sake of time but basically there are
ways to if you have an image you can
actually easily add what's called
skeleton or bones to that image and
that's another easy way to take a
picture you have and they could easily
start moving around so I'll pass it back
over to be dead to talk about our focus
group assaults so we had a series of
focus groups as we again used an
iterative process as we had you know our
initial episode we had a focus group to
kind of talk about some of the you know
questions that we were concerned about
but also get
other you know ideas from the group as
we continued this process and there was
a few themes that will highlight one was
the amount of texts uh be used whether
there was too much text on the screen
and kind of again distracted our
learners but if there wasn't enough text
for signposting then our learners felt
that some of the animation topics were a
little bit too abrupt and so over time
we've really learned to try to hone in
on that optimal balance and we're hoping
to really utilize a lot of that feedback
as we move forward um I again like the
real goal here is that we want the
characters so again
diabetes drugs are these static chemical
molecules and we're gonna
anthropomorphize them we're gonna give
them a story we're gonna give them a
personality and our learners felt that
that was actually quite helpful and it
was an ability for them to have a
memorable character in their mind that
they could springboard off of different
details that were important one thing
was you know as we move through the
classes of diabetes medications there
are classes where there are you know
eight or nine different drugs that have
similar but slightly different features
and so one of the pieces of the feedback
was user animation and use the colors
and what you know though the characters
are saying or what they're wearing is an
ability to help us distinguish some of
those details as you know we we got a
little bit fancier with the animation we
also learned though that too much accrue
Tremont's on the characters might
actually be somewhat distracting unless
it was very intentional and so the
intentionality of everything on the
screen was really a key feature and
again you know with the animation though
it was actually interesting for us
because with a digital native group we
thought that more high fidelity cartoon
you know animation would actually be
more engaging
but our learners really felt that you
know you can stick with simple
animations but you know really you know
looking at how you're using that
animation and telling a story you know
having a script we we initially started
with a talk show format and then we had
a little bit more of a documentary and
really though the feedback is the more
that you can tell us
it's gonna stick in our mind and so
we're really you know our upcoming
episode is almost gonna be like a
Western animation action movie so that
people hopefully can hold them for that
story hold onto the characters and have
long-term memory of the details that are
important so you know just like we
learned we want to have a summary at the
end of the video I'm gonna pass this
over to Brian for a summary of the
lessons that we've learned all right so
to wrap up I'm just gonna summarize some
of the lessons learned that weren't
already fully stated so there's limited
peer review literature on this so it's a
great opportunity to take what's out
there in the real world of people or
animating and combine it with what we do
know and do some cool scholarship time
is the greatest barrier so the key to
that is develop a team and we've had
some luck that finally after a few
episodes we have some other team members
coming on who are learning some of these
steps along the way and we're starting
to have a nice assembly line for making
these and if anyone else wants to join
for free and planning at the early
stages is key so feedbacking around the
script the storyboard character design
before you start doing all that work is
really important and then again we use
the grant for a lot of the hardware and
to get the ball rolling but really this
is pretty generalizable because so much
software is is free and available that
anyone could really do this
and then finally oh yeah so learners
were super excited about this and
hopefully you guys were too and again
you don't have to be an amazing artist
to accomplish this stuff and it was
really fun to like take drawing classes
online just for this project so future
directions so also the Center for
teaching and learning hooked us up with
Panopto so that allows us to get a lot
of interactiveness going with
multiple-choice quizzes and table of
contents and being able to change the
speed of the video all that it's
mentioned on the literature to be very
helpful to learners another episode so
the Western is coming growing the team
as I mentioned spreading the skills to
the department designing a workshop to
train other educators and these skills
and then hopefully eventually having an
appraisal tool where educators can have
a peer tool that they use to give
structured feedback to other people on
whatever multi
Media teaching they're doing and then
finally hopefully an Academy Award
something any questions yes do you guys
post these to YouTube or how do you
disseminate the videos good questions so
that has been a variable process
partially because we had to decide as
we're going how we want to collect
information on it so for our actual
target learner audience we've been
keeping it on Panopto where they log in
and we get to collect a nice rich data
about how long they're on there and and
how much they use it and then we've
shared it otherwise with like private
YouTube links and Google Drive and
things but so well you could of course
it's just a matter of in this right now
we're protecting a little while we study
it but absolutely it could be
disseminated in your focus group or did
it come up into any other situation
issues of aesthetics or effect and style
your the video you showed us was very
playful and then people who did anybody
think that's inappropriate or you know
we've levels of playfulness very
differently right and I think that
that's a great point we recognize that
although we have a Tartar over nerve
groups that are you know quote-unquote
Millennials some people have different
levels of wanting that that playfulness
or that types of style and so I think
that is a little bit of a challenge I
think knowing your learner group is
always the best way to target you know
your educational content and they think
if you're going to be having online
videos where you don't actually know
your learner
a little bit more challenging I think we
learned to kind of tone things back a
little bit but recognize that you know
what again that story and making those
characters memorable is actually
important so how are we going to do that
in a way that's not overwhelming
distracting or otherwise you know
bothersome to the learner and I think
that's where our focus which has been
really helpful because now we're
starting to even work with some of our
growing team around the storyboarding
and the character development so that
were not overshooting in terms of
hitting that optimal amount of
engagement that you'd like did not lend
themselves well to this format like
something maybe that you were interested
in doing and then
no I think we I think we had some yeah
pared down if anything just because when
you become an expert in a drug you
actually end up knowing more than a
doctor needs to know daily basis
treating patients and so if anything was
paring down so like our next ones are
these um some of them are an injection
pen and originally we're saying well do
we need to didn't have you use the
injection pen so does the dragon's head
need to be shaken and then spin around
like the pen would be and we said nope
they don't need to learn that cuz that's
gonna change with a new product soon so
but yeah so if anything um yeah we
haven't run into anything that has been
a challenge to represent metaphorically
[Applause]
so first I'd like to start by way of
introduction who we are so in the middle
we have Kavya Kosh nude
he is a associate professor of
epidemiology at the Yale School of
Public Health
whose idea all of this was on the Left
we have Sonam Lama graduate of the Yale
School of Public Health and now a
research researcher at Yale New Haven
Hospital and then on the right we have
me just to remind myself to introduce
myself I'm an 8 day old PhD from the
psychology department thanks and I am
the one who built what we'll be talking
about so my role was mainly to feed
drips of inspiration to the other two of
them in terms of how to design a game
but the actual script was written by
Sonam the idea came from cavae and I I
just implemented implemented the thing
I'm way down at the implementation level
in terms of what we did we were
interested in using a simulation based
approach to teaching epidemiology
students about real world crises going
on about how they would approach
something like the cholera crisis in
Yemen from an epidemiological
perspective and there's a few nice
things about simulation based learning
it's it holds your problem-solving
skills
it's very immersive it's very
interactive it's very dynamic and it's
very very memorable when you do it so
recently last semester I believe we had
the privilege of doing the simulation
with the Naval War College
where you've got like 30 people in a
room all trying to figure out how to
help some hypothetical nation deal with
some hypothetical crisis so in this case
I think we were helping the government
of Honduras deal with some big public
health crisis and you had to come and
each of us had different roles and
represented different groups so for
example I represented the US Army or the
US Navy I should say I was Admiral
wooden Berg and I came in with all of my
my warships full of medical supplies and
I had to dump them onto the the people
of Honduras and the thing is that it's a
very interactive scenario you're there
for hours of the day you have actual
professors at the Naval War College
guiding you through all this you've got
these figurines that they made of the
representing the different warships or
vessels that you have and it's a it's a
very involved process so as a result
even though it's amazing it's also very
expensive it's very time-consuming and
it doesn't scale very well it doesn't
scale well at all so with that in mind
we were hoping to take inspiration from
this kind of approach but applying it to
public health and you know using using a
method that can better scale and be sort
of exported to the rest of the world
easier so we had hoped to create an
online game essentially that would allow
people to go through what it would be
like to be an epidemiological research
or sort of aid worker in Yemen while
this crisis is about unfolding and we
did this by simply making a basic simple
interactive fiction game have any of you
played like text-based adventure games
before like Zork or Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy this sort of thing for
those of you who are unfamiliar
essentially you are placed in some
scenario and you have some set of
actions you can take like hey you're in
your bedroom and you could do things
like pick up your toothbrush and brush
your teeth and stuff like that by typing
into this kind of interface but given
that when we looked at our students who
we had in these this classroom this is
designed for a course by the way the
cafe is teaching and given when we look
the students they weren't necessarily
familiar with this kind of interface so
we use a much simpler sort of
multiple-choice based interface to say
okay here's where you are here the
actions you can take now and based on
the choices that they make the scenario
unfolds in a different fashion right so
it's kind of like a
choose-your-own-adventure sort of thing
like if you've read an RL stein
goosebumps novel or something it's like
turn to page 48 except we do the page
turning for you and we're based on
coffees interest cover is an
epidemiology professor he's big into the
cholera crisis in Yemen this is a huge
problem I learned because he told me and
I say it's because he told me in the
sense that it's not really getting much
coverage it's it's this massive massive
massive crisis millions of people
affected it the scale of loss is is hard
to describe so it seems like a good
testbed for this kind of approach so
actually because this is completed this
is already been administered his his
class it's a relatively small class I
think it's about a dozen people but
they've gone through this this game and
everything so I thought we'd we'd spend
less time talking about the process and
everything I just made it with very
basic web technologies so it's easily
exported easily transmitted to other
people you could go online and use it
now for yourself but we'll just let's
just walk through a little bit so for
example this is the this is the entry
screen we're not going to linger on here
there's a lot of text as a lot of
reading for people to do but we can go
through some things there's a lot of
video embedded throughout the throughout
the game because this is a learning tool
this is for people to learn about what's
going on in Yemen what the scale of loss
is like there are many links throughout
for people to live in about the
background so this is a big background
knowledge slide this is like you know an
hour of reading practically you have to
learn about the the the culture of Yemen
you have to learn about the local health
system all sorts of stuff you need to
learn about what deficiencies there are
currently but once you've read
everything then you can go in this is
one more video and
start the game so for example you start
off by flying to Yemen and you're
meeting people that you're gonna be
working with and you're reading articles
on the news pickin on the plane that are
in the newspaper that you spot and then
you land at the airport and you you're
met with your first set of choices so as
you exit the plane you see a car waiting
for you and your team
there are militant groups with guns
driving around the airport the place is
deserted except for a few officials from
international relief organizations
unloading their aid materials from their
car book aircrafts you're curious about
the situation and want to speak to
someone who do you speak to so now you
can decide that you're gonna talk to aid
officials you're gonna talk to the
militant so you're gonna get into your
car let's let's just go with something
round and the order of these buttons is
randomized so you don't from play
through to play through so for example
what if we wanted to talk to the
militants they seem like a nice group of
guys to talk to you oh you're done
you've been captured and now you need to
start over so if we start over you get
taken back for now to the like part
where you need to learn how to be a
person in this environment this is where
you learn all your regulations is where
you learn that you're not supposed to
talk to militants so you come back here
learn that and move on if we talk to eat
officials we're talking to them and now
they're telling you here we're here for
it we've been here for a couple of weeks
this is a colleague from grad school
that you've met before and they asked
you to join them if you join them up
you've been captured again because
you're not supposed to stray from your
team you've gone off into a dangerous
environment right so we're really trying
to hammer in this point that you you
follow you follow the security protocols
but suppose you get into your car then
you can start to do things you can do
all sorts of things from there from
there on does that make sense yeah and
that's that's basically how the game
unfolds and you you go from arriving in
Yemen to eventually meeting one of the
the princess of Yemen and all sorts of
stuff and trying to figure out how to
how to best approach this crisis
so it's already been administered this
is done we used the money from the
Rosencrantz grant to essentially pay me
and Sonam to make this kava had the idea
for all of this coffee provided guidance
all throughout Sonam actually wrote this
scenario so all that text there was like
95% Sunnah and then I just built the
infrastructure that allowed people to
click buttons and do what have you so in
terms of feedback generally it's been
very very positive people are learning
all about the essentially that culture
effects these sorts of things which is
not necessarily something you would
think from first principles you might
think that there's a one-size-fits-all
approach to public health or to dealing
with huge crises of of disease we also
throughout the game we also make a note
of how much this affects the people
working there so you as a worker gonna
see some pretty horrific stuff and that
can affect how you how you engage with
that kind of environment and that you
need to take time to to care for
yourself throughout that and lastly it
we want to have a home that even though
this is just a series of videos and
texts and and pictures it was immersive
for people that people felt connected to
this scenario so for next steps we were
hoping to sort of implement a decision
tree printout so as you know if each
decision is dependent on your previous
decision and it's a big branching tree
structure but by the time you get to the
end of the game it's nice to be able to
see where you went wrong what you could
have improved on so we'd like to
implement essentially like a big flow
chart of what decisions you have made
throughout that's a little bit easier
said than done but it is doable so
that's one of our next steps another
thing is that we could provide better
guidance on what exactly is an ideal
response in some cases perhaps even with
all the background we gave them it may
not have been the case that it's obvious
what the ideal answer would be in a
given in a given situation so we'd like
to provide more feedback about that
and then new variations of this so this
was all from the
effective of someone working with
medicine like I think with msfn medicine
sans fronteirs Without Borders but you
can imagine we're coming and from the
World Health Organization or you're
coming as a US Army worker and each of
those different groups would have very
different interests and ways of
approaching the scenario and lastly
because this is a this is an online tool
it's very very small it's a single file
it's just some pictures and things this
is very easily exported to people around
the world people all over you could go
online using the link that was up
earlier yourself and yeah that's
basically it thank you so much for
everything
[Applause]
stated either specific or general goal
for the game and when do you know when
you arrived is it final yes
the the goal for the game is essentially
so let's actually go back to the
yeah so you you will know you've reached
the end of the game because we tell you
this is the end of the game you get to
go back home
once you're done but the problem is that
this is an unfolding crisis and there is
no no way to resolve this and part of
the lesson is that you are just a little
cog in a tiny machine tuning onward yeah
does that answer your question
yeah these are the things that you've
done these are this is where you sort of
didn't maximize your potential agreed
that that's part of the the idea of the
the decision tree printout as well yeah
you're right yes it's really cool one
thing I did notice is that there is a
lot of text yes and I was wondering if
you had thought about maybe making it an
audio thing instead of text mmm if
anybody commented on the amount of text
yeah um in the very beginning there's a
lot more text than later on because the
beginning is so background heavy we
incorporated a lot of the background
sort of reading that would be for the
class into the the very beginning of it
but you're right about that
nobody commented on the heaviness of the
text the nice thing about text is that
it's easier to to transmit text is much
smaller than equivalent audio files or
audio files would make it much more
engaging I think that's definitely
something to consider I think it's cool
and engaging yes sorry you had a
question next to know just how long does
it take to progress with all the
readings I think it takes like a couple
of hours basically the readings are
relatively short there's lots of them
but they're relatively should two to
three hours yes
percent in this way did you build into
this Oriflame a bit like a framework so
that it would be easy for maybe a
faculty member somebody to say to give
you structure yeah
yes this is this is this is a very
generalized thing I can build these very
very easily now once once you give me a
clear clearly labeled weird document
with like this is the path that you take
this can be made very easily this
wouldn't take it wouldn't take me more
than like a week to do basically experts
in the field and if you're in the midst
of making a decision that you're
struggling over ohso you mean built
built into the game a sort of Skype like
interface where I could then chat with
say you as an as an expert in stuff I
feel like that would be I'll so I feel
like it would be easier to incorporate
to just use available tools for that
incorporate like say Skype or discord or
slack or something into the game rather
than try to build that infrastructure
from scratch that would depend entirely
on the availability of the experts
experts time is expensive and this is
designed for public health students who
are paying an achilles amount of tuition
to the school but still not enough I
think to get that kind of individualized
care yes
and have somebody filmed in the field
saying oh I see you're in section yes
yes yes that's that's great and I feel
like that that there's a lot of synergy
potential for synergy there with our
first speaker who was hoping to have
students generate teaching clips of
themselves we could use that that that
infrastructure to generate those clips
that's right cool thank you so much I'm
Sarah Schaefer I'm one of the faculty
members in the Department of Neurology
specifically with a focus on movement
disorders which for those of you who
don't know is Parkinson's disease
tremors and things like that and my
presentation is on the development of
interactive video based modules for
movement sorters education so the
population that I'm currently targeting
is neurology residents but as you'll see
as I go through it I think that this a
lot of levels could be made out of what
I've done so far and it could be it
could be designed for all different
levels including medical students
primary care providers community
neurologists and even fellows in
movement disorders so the problem the
reason that I wanted to do this is going
through residency I actually wanted to
go into movement disorders and I was
still getting so little exposure that by
the time I graduated I felt far more
comfortable dealing with an acute
intracranial hemorrhage than with
Parkinson's disease even though
Parkinson's disease is an enormous ly
common is enormous ly common in the
population and I think that this limited
exposure to movement disorders has
translated into a limited interest by
neurology residents in movement
disorders in 2017 462 fellowship spots
in movement disorders there were only 47
applicants and with the aging population
and Parkinson's disease being the
biggest thing that we see this is
obviously a problem so the status quo
for neurology education in movement
disorders and other outspeed outpatient
special teases they get a clinic here or
there and they get lectures but nobody
goes to lectures I'm sure every
department has the same problem and they
don't correlate with what they're seeing
so the lectures we do a two-week block
once a year and somebody could be on
their outpatient rotation during that
time or they could be on stroke or they
could be on neuro ICU and they're not
seeing any of these things and so
there's no they don't close the loop in
terms of what they're clinically seeing
also short attention spans especially I
don't know if any of you are Millennials
but in the Millennial population they
they're not paying attention for more
than 15 minutes or so to lectures and
there are a lot of variable learning
styles levels and paces of learning and
I wanted to build something that was
going to be able to cater to to that and
and accommodate all of these different
issues so I proposed designing online
interactive learning modules that will
use real patient videos so that they get
the experience of actually seeing a
patient with these disorders while
they're learning about the disorders and
accommodates a variety of learning
styles and paces they can go through the
modules at their own pace at their own
time and I used a combination of visual
and auditory and all sorts of different
ways to make the media so that people
who are visual learners or auditory
learners or other types of learners
would be able to learn from the modules
obviously it's flexible they can access
them at anytime any day or you know day
or night and they're very easy to
disseminate so the first step was I
created so movement disorders as a
fields that where their idea the
movement disorder society's idea of
medical education is to film a guy
standing next to a PowerPoint slide and
then split-screen that with his
PowerPoint presentation that's literally
what they have on their website as their
education right so in addition to that
there is
no there's actually very little by way
of a scaffolding for how to approach
movement disorders the language that we
use is all over the place there's a lot
of debates within the field it's it's
completely ridiculous and so the first
thing that I had to do was come up with
a scaffolding actually in order to say
these are the words that I want you to
use these are the words that apply to
this movement disorder and these are the
words that apply to this movement
disorder and that had actually never
been done so I came up with first a a
tree mod model and that was shot down by
my division head and I eventually came
up with and as another scaffolding that
I'll show you on made that into an
introductory video that's about seven
minutes that they watched before doing
any of the modules and then the modules
are based on that scaffolding and then I
plan for ten modules covering basic
movement disorders I wanted in this
first round to really cover the stuff
that's common
so Parkinson's disease essential tremor
tics etc and eight modules are now
complete and two are in production so
this is the introductory video as you
can see my scaffolding over here and up
here I have an example tremor it's an
involuntary loop in involuntary rhythmic
oscillatory movement and then over here
on the next slide of this of the
introductory video I say okay we're
using the word oscillatory what does
that actually mean it's alternating
agonist and antagonist muscles like you
see in a seesaw going back and forth
causing a tremor so this sort of
introduces you to the language
introduces you to the scaffolding so
that you can go into the modules with a
good idea of what you're talking about
and what the words mean and then to
create the media we primarily used
Camtasia for
those of you who are not familiar this
is the Kemp what Camtasia looks like
this is the video that we're creating
this is a real patient video that we
inserted into here and then we put text
and you can animate it and voice over
and do all sorts of things I also used
PowerPoint you can voice over PowerPoint
with Camtasia and record record that and
we've created 90 videos so far for the
eight modules which I will show you I'm
not going to show you actual videos
because that will take too much time but
I'll show you examples of screenshots
that we did so these are some of the
screenshots so up here I had one of my
neurology colleagues whose artistic draw
this brain and then Brian Brown actually
animated it so that the thalamus pops
out and pops back in and it shows you
this was actually for this essential
tremor model module and telling you
about deep brain stimulation and why
that works for essential tremor this is
another example where I took real
patient MRI scans and showed normal
versus abnormal side to side this is the
hummingbird sign which is why this
little hummingbird is here you can see
that the pons and the midbrain looks
like a hummingbird this is a split
screen where I have a tremor flowsheet
and I'm showing you on the left the
gentleman with his actual tremor
happening and saying oh look there's
this tremor during this and so he has a
rest tremor and there's his tremor
during this so he has a postural tremor
and here's another example of where I
had a video of a gentleman walking and I
was able to pause stop the video to
point things out and then have him and
restart the video to have him walk so
that they knew what they were looking
for here's a this is the exact same
patient doing the exact same examination
pre and post deep brain stimulation
surgery this is an inter operative video
of an awake patient getting deep brain
stimulation surgery
they're turning the DBS on and off and
showing how it's helping with the tremor
while he's in the Loire this I'm still
figuring this out but this is in actual
chalk talk where I'm able to draw on the
screen the graphs while I'm talking
about what I'm drawing and this is an
example of one of our wrap-up videos
that we have at the end of every module
where we do the the basic learning
points with video videos that we've
shown in the modules so that was the
media and then there's the module
creation so we ended up putting the
modules into Qualtrics and thanks Gary
for all your help with that we went
through a lot of different iterations of
what we're gonna do and finally landed
on Qualtrics and I hired students to do
this based on worksheets of how I wanted
the modules to flow that I wrote myself
and the great thing about Qualtrics is
that you can actually use display logic
for conditional answers so if they
answer a question correctly it can go to
one to the correct and say oh this is
correct because blah blah if they answer
incorrectly can say this is incorrect
because blah blah try again and they can
go back so it's like a
choose-your-own-adventure like that
other guy was saying yes where you it
goes based on what you actually do
we ended up housing the videos on
YouTube we started with Panopto but it's
and when we originally use Panopto it
could be accessed outside of Yale but in
the middle of me making these modules
they got rid of that feature and I want
to be able to use the modules outside of
Yale so we had to move all of them to
unlisted videos in YouTube and each
module leads the learner through a
description so rythmic is a descriptive
term phenomenology tremors of
phenomenology
nosis essential tremor workup and
treatment comparing and contrasting
between and within modules for different
patients and I had several experts
review each module for content and
modified them based on what they said so
this is Qualtrics these are this is
display logic where it says if you
answer the the correct answer goes to
this screen if you answer the incorrect
answer it goes to this screen and this
is what the module looks like so we have
you can see that it has like the same
things that it had in the introductory
video of descriptive terms they can use
it on that on their phone as well this
is an example of not a question but just
a description of hey isn't this
interesting look at this video to find
out more about this so we're currently
piloting the modules with nine neurology
residents and fellows and the feedback
so far has been really positive but we
haven't quite gotten through the pilot
yet we did a pretest we're gonna do a
post-test and survey and do some semi
structure two interviews after we're
done and then as far as future
directions we are currently reaching out
to other residency programs to do a
multicenter trial of these modules of
the first ten modules for the next two
thousand eighteen to nineteen academic
year and there's some interest from the
American Academy of Neurology
program directors consortium they're
starting a medical education Research
Consortium and they want to potentially
use this which would mean it would
probably be used piloted at about about
twenty programs and I'm gonna be
applying for the American Board of
psychiatry and neurology educational
grant which will give me enough time and
money for the next two years to make
levels like I was talking about in terms
of a medical student level or beginner
level an intermediate level in an
advanced level and ultimately
distribution I haven't quite figured
that out yet it is in a format where it
is distributable
outside of
Yale so once we decide who we're gonna
give it to and how it'll be easy to do
so this is the creative team that's me
obviously Lina has been instrumental in
helping with inputting Qualtrics and
paraca spend making videos for me Brian
did the animation and Stacy did the
brain and Moises did some of the other
anime or the other pictures that were in
there like the seesaw people the content
team this is these are all the people in
my division and Jeremy molars my was my
faculty advisor when I was a fellow and
I should have put technical team like
Matt and Gary and Tripp and everybody
who's helped me figure it out
Camtasia and Qualtrics and and all that
stuff so that's it any questions so I I
think this works great as you know you
start and you follow through the path is
there any plans to make like a reference
mode so once people have passed there
and kind of graduated
is there any way for them to then go
back and immediately be able to look at
you know save the videos on essential
tremors without like out of the context
of this so the so they can go into
individual modules easily and within the
modules we have a table of contents so
there's description phenomenology
diagnosis treatment etc so they could go
to an individual section of that table
of contents and skip the previous part
but the videos individually are not
available anywhere at the moment but
they could be and then how do you plan
on implementing this into the career
say like a med student once it gets
there do you do you think this will just
be you know use it if you want it or
will it be mandated that they pass
through it or so for so for the
residents it's going to be mandated that
they do it during their outpatient
clinical rotation and so that's usually
two or four weeks and they would do it
at their leisure during that time for
medical students you know the medical
school is pretty protective of required
things for their medical students I
could envision it as being most useful
during their clerkship their neurology
clerkship but that clerkship is you know
four weeks and they're learning all of
Neurology so I I might pick you know
half of the modules or three or four of
the modules that I think are the most
you know really need to know and and
make those required and the rest
optional yes you need to like sort of
scale this so you need more control it's
super glitchy I really hate Qualtrics
actually it's no it's it's working it's
working great for this but it is glitchy
I mean it throws all sorts of wrenches
at me and I'm like what are you what is
happening yeah yeah yeah if you not good
you know if you can tell me how to use
that what up what did you use I built it
oh yeah well greets can I have it okay
if you I'm not okay I am okay great that
would be great about having a framework
so that yeah
Sara we just have to you know there's a
way to import like a word bag or
something oh yeah I imagine that you
have to be manual it's a little bit
about it's a little bit more manual but
it's very it's literally just
transliteration as opposed to like doing
all this crazy display logic and
Qualtrics messing up your life and yeah
very on transparent yeah oh it will like
all of a sudden delete something and I'm
like where did it go
or like the next button will be over
here randomly and I'm like why just
isn't a company anymore everything
you've built is gone
whereas so long as I have the web my
remain like okay well I would love to
talk further it would be it would be
really great because call tricks is
driving me nuts yeah
which you can get through Yale because
that way you could I think maybe
organizing that I'm imagining you to be
just there just kind of thrown up there
you don't have a lot of control over
ones through there well they're they're
unlisted I mean you can anybody can
access them if they have the link but
they're not searchable so yeah but I
don't know what an s3 bucket is both of
you
Panopto was great and it was great when
I was allowed to share them outside of
Yale but you know that went away so
originally yeah when I originally
conceptualized this I had put in my
budget like for coding something that
would allow me to do this not in one of
these platforms but ultimately we
decided that the plot this platform was
the easiest thing to do but I agree with
you that it's not the final option yeah
thanks Joe thanks for bearing with me to
the bitter end I'm Monica Bravo I'm a
lecturer in the history of art and the
program and ethnicity race and migration
and to this project I'll try to keep it
short it grew out of a class that I've
been teaching I taught it for the last
time last spring it's called visual
culture of the national parks and the
course really came out of I've sort of
inspired by the centennial of the
national parks in 2016 as well as the
Trump inauguration which of course gave
rise to the rogue National Park Twitter
accounts and it's a course that is the
way of teaching American art across a
variety of different media and sort of
in a non period dependent way as well
the courses cross listed between my two
departments the history of our at the
program and ethnicity race and migration
as well as environmental studies and it
should be cross listed with American
Studies too so it's quite an
interdisciplinary class with a very
interdisciplinary group of students as
well the two guiding questions for the
course which relate to this last point
is are how does and did the visual
culture of the National Parks create
support and narrate a particular vision
of u.s. national identity at his
distinct historical moments and for whom
are the parks and whose interests are
represented through its visual culture
so the fur in the first iteration of the
course I teamed up with Pam Patterson
and wonderful colleague of trips here at
the Center for teaching and learning and
she helped me to develop a course
website that I used last spring it was a
combination of course press and time map
and so students could map objects and
they could map events but it also was
kind of a clunky Pat platform for us and
didn't actually see a larger audience
outside of that course so for this
iteration of the the project and with
the help of the Rosencrantz grant I
wanted a more robust site and one that
would be more integrated into the
content of the class so students
wouldn't be creating written assignments
just for me they would be creating
things that would ultimately be made
available here and to a larger public so
through this process we chose to use Oh
Mecca as the platform for the project
and you can sort of read more about it
here it's something
has gained some currency across the
humanities and I worked with the team
not only of Pam who was really really
helpful in this process
talking talk to librarians around campus
as well but I also worked with a
developer Marshall Jefferson and a
graphic designer Micah Barrett who
helped it make look who helped it look
really good because though Mecca does
not look this good right out of the box
so the project is where students are
actually building the collection as a
public resource that's available to a
general public as well as for other
educators it's not like this is a common
class this is one I invented it wasn't
easy to sort of find these resources and
so I thought we could kind of build a
collection together and so for one of
the assignment students has an option of
adding objects so they were asked to add
five objects and to kind of add the
metadata that would be related to them
so to give you an example here for
example the student adds an image they
could use dublin core and I'll show you
that interface very briefly actually
so here it was you know there's kind of
an out-of-the-box solution there's also
a way to kind of detail and give
examples for students of the kinds of
things that they should be adding in
these different moments the other thing
it allows them to do is to map their
object so they type in an inheritor and
address and this one is a mountain scene
so it's an ambiguous area does not show
up on the map but that was it allows
these objects to then show up on the on
the map for the collective as well so
those were did the first aspect of the
assignment another thing that they did
was these these are then organized into
different collections and these are
organized by medium here for example you
know students might choose kind of more
contemporary objects as well as historic
ones some of these things are in Yale's
collections many others are outside and
students have written as another
assignment for the course students were
asked to write to object descriptions
and so these are the kinds of texts you
might see for example at a meet at a
museum on the wall next to the object
and they're interpreting the objects
through these through these kinds of
texts that they're using and some of the
challenges for this was of course
consistency of object entries so things
like if they write like you know circa
1910 it won't appear in the timeline
which I'll show you in a moment
also things like permissions and credits
with something we talked about so using
things that are in fair use or that are
in the public domain things that are
created by the government of course are
in the public domain so a number of
students actually got interested in
things like the Instagram of the
National website and have added a number
of objects from
as well okay so I didn't really if you
can sort of see I I didn't want a
privilege kind of one point of access to
these objects so we have that you can
enter through the objects adds a hole
and search across them you can search by
collection say you're only interested in
photographs you can go immediately there
there's also this map feature which is
sort of maybe the most sort of
spectacular aspect but it allows you to
see the various objects that we've added
and it takes a minute to load generally
you can see that
so you could
interact with us here if you're not
interested in seeing the state borders
for example if you're only in truth or
if you're not interested in architecture
photographs it will limit your search in
this and this way too this is also the
Timeline feature so if you're only
interested in objects from a specific
period of time and you can see them here
and then of course you can interact with
individual objects through this platform
as well lots of objects in Yellowstone
and that's been sort of an interesting
feature of this project - it's seen
where many of the objects kind of tend
to cluster together will take us to
another object as well and so obviously
I was thinking about you know this isn't
just for educators it's not just for
somebody who's interested in visual art
but say you're planning on a trip to
Yellowstone you could come to this
resource and kind of look ahead and and
see what kinds of things have resulted
from this the visual culture of the
national price is really there's several
apocryphal stories there's one painting
for example by Thomas Moran that was
said to lead to actual legislation that
led to Yellowstone being preserved and
so it just to give you a sense of kind
of some of the importance of these
projects but students we're really
adding objects that they thought should
be included and that they were
interested in the final assignment for
the course is actually for each student
to create a final exhibition so they'll
be adding more objects that they will
need for their Colet for their
exhibitions but they're also using some
of the objects that we've also that
we've already added here a couple couple
of just sample ones that we've done so
if you check back in a week when their
final assignments are due you will
hopefully see some some of the projects
that the students have done this is a
sample just to show you what it will
look like so a kind of landing page
image
texts to contextualize it and then
bringing objects into a different kind
of communication with one another and
they're still doing things like
including we're excited at the end of
their project so that we have kind of
the academic aspect to this too but I
really encourage students to kind of
tell a story and the way through these
exhibitions and to give you some sense
of what projects students are working on
one is working on food so she's kind of
talked about bison and it's one of the
subsections of her exhibition she's
gonna talk about grazing she also saw
some menus and some of the collections
at Yale that she was interested in and
and one of the questions she's also
interested in as the kind of rise of
ethnic food at certain parks I'm
depending so like if it's a text at
Texas National Park and no a lot of this
stuff is available online and she's
bringing them together in this context
another student is interested in selfie
culture so she's kind of thinking about
how to tell that story through these
artworks as well so this is a project
that I'll continue to build on and add
in future iterations and there's still
some tweaking that we want to do at this
stage but much of the rosencrantz grant
for this project went to pain the
developer and the designer to make this
kind of such a visually appealing
project and but I'm happy to take
questions now
and suggestion have you reached out to
any of the parks themselves yeah I think
that's the next stage so I do have
contact in various National Park sites
on the one hand I like that it's
independent on the other hand I would
like for it to be kind of recognized
officially by the National Park Service
at some stage at this stage also there's
about 115 objects so it's not a very
robust collection but it will continue
to grow and I see an envision that the
possibility of growing this is so in the
right last spring when I taught the
course students weren't adding
collections so this was kind of one of
the innovations I
that this project and the Rosencrantz
grant helped me to do but yeah they're
already going to be adding more objects
for their exhibitions too so it will
only continue to grow as a collection
but yeah I'd certainly like to talk more
to National Park Service individuals
about this doing web native omeka
authentic exhibits as opposed to
Illustrated essays and it's a loaded
question because I've worked with the
mecha before and I feel like that's a
tough transition first yeah yeah that's
a really good question and neat line of
course is a plug-in that we've also made
available to students and I won't get
into it now but it is kind of a more
robust storytelling environment for that
so I just I just ran into one my
students over break and she was talking
about the exhibition that she's working
on now and we I you know this is the
first time I've made this kind of
assignment I don't have a lot of
expectations in terms of what they're
doing but I am encouraging them to think
about how they interact with the web
things like breaking up paragraphs
adding visuals like so that you're not
just kind of constantly paging through
text or so those things aren't
segregated from one another but I think
what this also allows is interactivity
within the site so if you're clicking on
an object it will bring you back to that
object file or the object card is
another way we've thought about that and
yeah and you know people in CTL will
really help me think through that like
there is steps of like adding the
objects I had to check kind of all the
objects to make sure they were kind of
consistent across that and then things
like adding object descriptions
typically in classes I have students
write what's called a formal analysis in
art history and that's an exercise in
close looking so here students wrote
instead for the web platform so we've
been talking about those kinds of things
and I think it is a really useful kind
of skill for them to have too
and that is about the object century I
feel like I'm hearing that a lot more in
humanities work these days
this object century oh yeah no I think
you're right I think you're right um
part of it is like it's deep privilege
in artwork as the as that signifier in
the course is a visual culture of course
um
Yale tends to be kind of conservative in
artistry and so but we are you know some
of the students have added things like
Patagonia hats and match boxes as well
as objects or like that somebody
included an ad for cigarettes that has
the Grand Canyon in the background so
it's it's been really cool to see the
kinds of objects students are interested
in but yes they would say in the
humanities as a whole there's a big push
towards object centered research and
thinking about what the object can tell
you not just what the archives can tell
you yeah that's such a good question and
I would love for this to kind of be
publicly accessible and editable in the
future but that I think that would be
the big challenge to it so for the
students in this course I checked their
object description so we went through a
round of edits before they added them
and that was in part so that they would
feel comfortable what that about what
they had written and knowing that it was
going to be made public I had to get of
course permissions for the students to
attach their names to exhibitions as
well as to the objects that they've
added but yeah I think it is like kind
of checking in with them and talking to
them and providing opportunities for
them to have me check things before it
becomes available to a general public
[Music]
yeah I wonder if there's any written
resistance or any feeling of a kind
courage on the back that kind of asking
or mandating your students right right
um well that that's a good question and
I guess I'll find out with final
evaluations um no I think this I think
that I'm encouraging it's not unusual in
art history part in particular to have
an assignment be something like an
exhibition or to write an object
description which as I said is very
similar to a formal analysis and is just
a sort of different platform so I think
for me what it has been it had Pam come
into the classroom right in our second
week it's been kind of bringing them
along and talking to them and making
clear that part of the project of the
class is to have this public engagement
beyond the classroom and we've talked a
lot about you know what kind of writing
is appropriate for a general public
versus a paper that they write privately
for me and so I didn't give anything
they've been really excited about kind
of finding cool things and sharing them
and adding them here but it is yeah it
could be a problem see that thank you
[Music]
you